on the hill tonight for the giants will
be the right-hander logan webb
webb who is at 24 years of age
comes into this particular start with a
a record of six and three in a 296 era
last 10 games the giants are 901 when he
toes a rubber he's been very consistent
we mentioned a moment ago patrick mazeka
a very late substitution for james
mccann who went out to warm up marcus
stroman in the bullpen earlier but was
scratched
back to webb
nemo is retired first pitch to pete
alonso broken back grounder to third
charging longoria he's got it and he'll
throw to first in time two down
[Applause]
strike three called he back door with
that slider right at the knees right on
the corner
stro see his numbers he got a win in his
last start against the nationals he went
five in the third and gave up a run
up the middle and just past
base head
so wade is aboard and here is tommy la
stella
that ball is hit well
deep right center field way back there
and
adios
a two run homer for tommy lestella
and that was a big fly
right where the ballpark starts to open
up
into the match bullpen two-nothing
giants
boy and he did it in a two-strike count
and a half swing and posey went around
strike three and strowman has his first
doubt
here's the pitch and jd swings and
misses slider struck him out
right to belt
two down
that one ball was hit hard
here's a big bouncer toward the middle
to his left crawford's got it from
behind the bag he slings one to first in
time to get vr the ball one strike
strowman ready
pitch
bounce back toward the mound behind
second glove by vr steps on second
throws to first for a double play
oh two from strowman and he chases the
slider for strike three
wanted to the count
struck him out
saved that breaking ball for a
two-strike surprise third strikeout for
logan webb
0-2 strowman bunts and it's good third
base side longoria down the line to
barehand it strowman not running
[Applause]
and the check swing did he go yes
dennis sogna rings him up
[Applause]
3-2 pitch
is hit in the air fairly deep to center
field nimmo though has a beat on it as
he approaches the track and hauls it in
in left center for out number one
again the 3-2
and that's hit to center field nemo
going back got turned around but finds
it that makes the catch
another full count for strowman
and posey takes strike three calls up
sinker on the outside corner
5-0 there's a drive by conforto into
deep left center field and that ball is
off the wall it's picked up by ostremski
he fires back in but sliding into second
with a one-out double is michael
conforto here in the fourth inning
grounded down to third longoria behind
the bag the running throw on a hop it
gets on by conforto did not break from
second initially he goes to third and
he'll stop there and jd is safe at
first on the ground and it could be two
crawford weird hop runs to the bag for
one throws to first got him double play
so bell tries to bunt but don't do that
against strong he's just too good i mean
you just can't bond against strowman's
degroms athletes like that the jump
throw
when's the last time you saw a pitcher
make a jump throw to first base to
retire a bunner
crawford unloads one to center field but
this one's playable
and nemo's been busy tonight
good slider by strowman to strike out to
strumsky
pitch
slow bouncer up the first base side belt
gloves it right behind the bag two steps
from there and he gets the unassisted
put out
vr is retired
got him swinging
they only got her to chase out of the
zone so strikeout number six
and he swings and lines one on the left
for a base hit
no but necessary
marcus schulman with a ringing single
hit the 1-0 pitch
line drive caught at second by la stella
[Applause]
alonso a little dribbler that's going to
be a tough play webb and posey kind of
collided and webb still made the play
wow
that's pretty athletic play right there
but you're seeing two guys
pitching tonight that really do cover
their position
stella swings and misses strike three
good pitch there from stroman the split
change
it's trailed two nothing strowman from
the wind up his pitch swinging him is
strike three boy posey has looked bad
tonight strowman eight strikeouts
tonight that matches his season high and
he's now fanned four in a row
and on pitch number 100 he gets crawford
to retire the side nine strikeouts a
season high for marcus
did he swing yes and then play that part
made the call himself
dug out of the dirt by posey who tagged
him out and
now the vr is getting into it with
jeremy react
now webb will try it again
straight three caught in the inside
corner
broke back and caught the corner so
eight strikeouts for logan webb seventh
inning stretch time here strowman comes
back longoria's had two hits tonight
against strowman one and infield it
there's a high drive in the deep left
field this has a chance way back there
and goodbye he was on the injured list
for two months his first home run
since coming back that has to feel good
three-nothing giants home run number ten
for number ten
sinker down and in drop the head
and ride it right on out of here and
that's a big big run
giants now lead three nothing one out
and now alonso will be the batter
[Applause]
and alonso rockets one to left field
back goes wade near the wall it's out of
here
pete alonso with a two-run homer to get
the mets back in it number 26 for alonso
and the mitts get on the board in the
eighth and they cut the giants lead to
three to two on one big swing by alonso
one two coming and mcneil pokes one the
other way
that's down for a base hit and it
bounces away backed up nicely though by
wade and mcneil will have to hold it
first strike three caught on the inside
corner
[Applause]
off of belt
he runs to the bag
just got him tying run at second mcneal
two out top of the ninth three to two
san francisco
and kevin takes strike three called a
slider on the inside corner
and for the first time this year the
mets have lost five games in a row and
for the first time since may the fifth
they have fallen below 500.